is are praying for Parliament on a
regular basis
it comes from Luke chapter 10.
which of these do you think was a
neighbor to the man who fell into the
hands of robbers
the expert in the law replied
the one who had mercy
on him
and Jesus told him
go and do likewise
good leadership
rooted in service for others
is essential
for the goods of any society
the short passage I read at the
beginning is an interaction between
Jesus and the Jewish religious leader
where Jesus in response to the question
who is my neighbor
tells the familiar story that we know as
the Good Samaritan
much has been made of that wonderful
responsive Story by Jesus
but often we forget that these
concluding remarks between Jesus and his
contemporary
are fundamental
the heart of the story is the one who
showed Mercy
reflecting the quality of Love
expected by Jesus
in the ancient Hebrew language the word
for mercy
speaks of the unconditional love that a
parent has
for their child
it is therefore a powerful and Primal
concept
indeed mercy and forgiveness
are at the very heart
of Christian identity
within the Christian tradition
we understand that we receive Mercy as a
gift from God through Jesus Christ
yet Jesus expects that a gift of such
magnificence
and Grace and magnitude
that is so freely given
and gladly received by us
should be personally expressed
in all of our relationships
love and mercy is not always easy
love for our neighbor
that person in need whoever they are
love
given
in every way that we can
love even for our enemies as Jesus said
is not a suggestion
but a command
love your enemies he said and pray for
them
to show Mercy then
and to act out of love
is not primarily a Feeling
but an act of the will
even when we are deeply hurt
and offended by someone else
it is to give to another
what they do not deserve
because we realize
that we are the recipients of Greater
Mercy
what then is most important when it
comes to the qualities of leadership
is it charisma
intelligence
real life experience
popularity
vision
or is it people who can be dependent
upon to show kindness
Grace
forgiveness
and A Generous Heart
and unconditional love and mercy
in every circumstance
thank you margarita
[Applause]
the next item of business is topical
questions and at question number one I
call Pam Gossel thank you presiding
officer to ask the Scottish government
whether it will provide an update on
targeted Council of funding for the
qualities and universities Minister
Jamie Hartford
since 2019-20 we've invested over 15 and
a half million pounds to provide almost
90 additional counselors and cause
universities exceeding a program for
government commitment to support the
recruitment of 80 such posts we have
committed to meeting our program
government commitment to provide
additional funding for the entirety of
Academic Year
2022-23 we're the only UK Nation funding
student council provision in this way
I thank the minister for that response
last week the education in children and
young People's Community Committee
published the college regionalization
report the report found that this
targeted Council funding was critical
for students
so can I ask the minister has demand for
men to health Council increased over the
four-year period
and which dedicated funding for councils
have been provided and how will future
demand for these Services be met if this
financial support is not available
beyond the end of this Academic Year
Minister well just on on that last Point
what I would say to Ms grossel is one of
the things we've committed to is taking
forward the publication of a student
mental health action plan that will be
forthcoming very shortly we have not
made any final decision in respect of
further funding beyond the end of the
year so no final decision has been taken
in that regard we recognize the
importance of the investment we've made
this far we do want to see that the what
has been done there to be enabled to
continue to support students through
what we know has been a difficult and
challenging time and fundamentally
that's what the mental health action
plan will continue to seek to respond to
hang also
thank the minister for that response
Minister we already know the DraStic
reduction some colleges will be making
in response to the smp's funding
settlement
one college is planning for staff
redundancies up to 25 over the next few
years this is not a unique situation 21
College principals have written to the
Scottish government pleading for help
these counselors can provide a
life-saving service for many students
who are struggling with their Mental
Health
following these please can I ask the
minister will he set out the
government's position on compulsory
redundancies and ensure that all college
students can access the services they
need Minister well just on the point
that Ms grossel has made around the
letter from the 21 College principles
I'm aware of that correspondence we will
of course as you would expect of the
government reply to that what currency
has been very close contact with college
principles over the last period to
discuss the very issues that we are
touching upon today have made clear as
clear to them as I am to Ms grossel
around our commitment to the stream
mental health action plan and what we
might be able to do in subsequent years
in relation to funding for colleges of
course we have leveraged in additional
resource four colleges for this coming
year but I would respectfully say to Ms
grossel it isn't good enough to stand
there as she does weaken week out to
call for additional funding for not just
this sector but virtually every sector
across government expenditure without
identifying where it'll come from so I
look forward to hearing RC where that
will come from now
thank you as members might expect
there's a lot of interest so concise
questions and responses will enable more
members to take part and can I call
co-captured
um thank you my understanding is that
since 2019 20 the Scottish government
has invested in almost 90 additional
counselors in colleges and universities
some of these institutions are of course
private organizations and have their own
role to play in ensuring provision for
the well-being of their students can the
minister say something about how the
work of these professionals including
those provided through Government
funding will complement the work of the
upcoming student Mental Health Plan
Minister well let me pick up an
important point that the crew capture
has made this year's right to identify
that the institutions that we're
providing funding for fundamentally have
a core responsibility here they
themselves have to make sure that they
are adequately responded to and
supporting their students in mental
health it needs now we've of course
assisted with that we provide a
substantial package of funding to
universities in culture for the less
additional funding to support the
recruitment of these councilors and
through our student mental health action
plan we will seek to build on that to
make sure that we're supporting
resilience and mental well-being of
students across the country Katie Clark
000 people have signed a petition to the
UK government calling for the creation
of a statutory legal duty of care for
students in higher education a duty of
care already exists for staff and for
students under 18. would the minister
explore introducing a statutory legal
duty of care for students in colleges
and universities Minister well I can't
earnestly say that it will be me that
said doing it of course but that is
something I think that the government
should reflect on
Willie Rennie
yes
it's a little bit more positive what the
minister says that no final decision has
been made about future funding but it
does leave these staff in limbo and I
hope that the minister will act with a
little bit more haste to make a quicker
decision about this because these Mental
Health Counselors have provided an
invaluable service for vulnerable
students across the college and
university sector so how much longer
will we have to wait Minister well I
understand the point that Mr rainy mixer
is one Arctic seriously because we do
have to try and give that Clarity he'll
understand of course we have to go
through the usual process that we
Undertake and we have made that
commitment to the student mental health
action plan which before coming very
soon and in my own perspective is that
we shouldn't disaggregate these issues
too much but I take on board the point
and it's something we need to provide in
terms of clarity to the institutions as
soon as possible Ross Greer thank you
the health and well-being Center shows
that for many young people challenges
with their mental health begin at school
before college or university so can ask
the minister for an update on what
progress has been made towards the house
agreement commitment that every young
person has a right to access in-school
mental health counseling if they so
require it which should hopefully in
turn reduce the demand for college and
university mental health support
services Minister well this is a field
reminder that we have adjected to
support the mental well-being of all
young people and it's going to continue
to provide 60 million pounds to local
authorities to award the commitment to
make sure that every secondary school
has access to counseling services
authorities across the country have
confirmed that all schools do have as
such a access Authority providers with
six monthly reports on the services and
the latest reports to be analyzed show
that just over 14 and a half thousand
young people access the service between
January and June 2022 with over six
thousand those young people reporting
improved outcomes with the majority of
the remaining people still accessing the
service and with their outcomes to yet
be captured but to report it in due
course question number two feigel
chowdry thank you thank you presiding
officer to ask the Scottish government
what action it is taking in response to
recent reported analysis by held equals
which shows that poverty-driven Health
inequalities are reducing life
expectancy amongst people who live in
the most deprived areas Minister Marie
Todd we are using all of the powers and
resources available to us to tackle
poverty reduce inequality increase
healthy life expectancy and thus create
a fairer Scotland the Scottish
government has allocated almost 3
billion across 22 to 23 to mitigate the
damage inflicted on households by the UK
government's cost of living crisis we're
providing free School meals increasing
the numbers of hours of free child care
we've already increased the Scottish
child payment to 25 pounds per week
supported 1.85 million households with
council tax reduction and operated all
benefits that we deliver will continue
to deliver free prescriptions
concessionary travel free personal
personal care and our Fair work agenda
thank the minister for that answer
as co-conventor of the cross-party group
on improving Scotland's health and as a
member of the social justice and Social
Security committee I'm well aware of the
disparities faced in Scotland in terms
of health in 2018 a study showed that a
boy born in Muir house had a life
expectancy of 13 years shorter than that
of a boy born and never in common
analysis from the health Foundation
reported that the average life
expectancy in Scotland has reduced by
4.4
years since 2013. in addition drug
related deaths have increased and are 18
times higher in the most deprived areas
when compared to the list can the
minister confirm what steps the Scottish
government have taken to address this
health inequalities and the specific
health conditions that
disproportionately affect those from the
most deprived areas minister so we
absolutely recognize
qualities and poverty and that's why
we're using all of the powers and
resources available to us to support
families as far as possible and to
tackle the underlying causes of
inequality in our national mission to
tackle child poverty we're also
um as you're aware being um on the cpgs
that you're in we're we're also
um
targeting people who have low incomes in
our reaching out to provide healthy
um life-changing
um sorry sorry
we are also targeting people who live in
poverty with means to stop smoking
measures like the minimum unit pricing
of alcohol which was aimed at the whole
population had a particular impact on
people who live in poverty and those who
live in poverty were the ones who were
most helped by that policy
I thank the minister for that answer
for individuals with diabetics poverty
driven Health inequalities are
preventing them from accessing
Technologies advance in the treatment of
their condition
this has been highlighted by diabetic
Scotland diabetics Tech cannot wait
campaign this technology has a potential
to change and indeed save the lives of
those with type 1 diabetics
it can also reduce serious complication
and the strain on the NHS
can the minister advise who are actually
it will take to tackle the inequalities
of access to the hybrid closed-loop
diabetics technology in relation to so
so a social economic background
Minister absolutely and it's a great
question those people have real
difficulty accessing Healthcare and
navigating Healthcare one of the reasons
that people who are experiencing Health
inequalities suffer poorer outcomes is
because the system fails to respond to
them and listen to them in the way that
it does for those from a wealthier and
more educated background who are more
able to advocate for themselves so
undoubtedly we will be making sure that
the system begins to listen to
absolutely everyone we have a whole lot
of money going into and I can write to
the member with details of how much
money there is going into those
particular diabetic Technologies it is a
tragedy that people one of the greatest
predictors of people's in health and
life expectancy is their wealth and it
is an absolutely brutal tragedy that
this Parliament is determined to tackle
and we will tackle it but we will need
cross part to support in order to make
the Bold decisions that do fundamentally
tackle the underlying causes of poverty
as well as ensure that people who are
living in poverty can access equal
Health Care
Emma Harper
thank you Poseidon officer the analysis
that Mr Chowdhury refers to it makes it
clear that 13 years of college Tory
austerity is now impacting every inch in
the UK Recent research by the Glasgow
Center for population Health also linked
to relate austerity to worsening health
outcomes in the 20 most deprived areas
of Glasgow and Dundee so all the cabinet
secretary just reiterate that the
Scottish government is committed to take
an action within its powers to tackle
the root causes of poverty and
Associated Health inequalities Minister
the member
the member is absolutely right to raise
this issue and in fact in fact foisal
Chowdhury also mentioned the key date of
2013 for being when we started to see
life expectancy reduce in Scotland that
is the academics tell us because of the
Tory lib Dem austerity measures that
they brought in in 2010 which which had
a direct doubt
which is the minister which is a a
policy which is absolutely
life-shortening for people in Scotland
it has had a life shortening impact on
people living in Scotland I hear them
chantering from a sedentary position 16
years the academics are exceptionally
clear on this point austerity the
political choice to pursue austerity
politics has been life-shortening for
people in Scotland and continues to be
so
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you that concludes topical
questions
the next item of business is the
selection of the parliament's nominee as
first Minister and a note explaining the
procedures to be followed this afternoon
has been made available to members
I have received four valid nominations
for selection of the parliament's
nominee for first Minister and I will
now announce the nominations in
alphabetical order
the nominations are Alex Cole Hamilton
Douglas Ross Anna sarwar and Hamza Yusuf
and I will ask each nominee to speak in
support of their candidacy for up to
five minutes and after the nominees have
spoken members will be asked to cast
their vote
for their preferred candidate a separate
vote will be called for each candidate
and members can vote
once only once and once all voting has
been completed any member who has not
yet voted will be invited to cast a vote
to abstain and there will be a short
suspension while the result is verified
and I will then announce the results of
voting
a candidate will be elected if an
overall majority is obtained if no
majority is obtained the candidate or
candidates with the smallest number of
votes will be eliminated and I would ask
members to note that if we have a vote
between only two candidates all that is
required as a simple majority for one of
the candidates to be elected and members
may wish to record an abstention and no
account if those votes will be taken in
establishing whether a simple majority
has been achieved and we will then
proceed to a further round of voting but
I now call on Alex cool Hamilton
thank you very much indeed presiding
officer presiding officer I Rise to
speak to my candidacy for the office of
first minister of Scotland I am a
candidate in this contest because this
is a democracy and democracies are about
the presentation of differing Visions as
to how things could be about bringing to
the forward the priorities of the
constituents who sent us all here to
this place here and now we are as far as
it is possible to be from a Scottish
parliamentary election we are mid-stream
and have a governing party in disarray
adrift and out of ideas it brings to
mind the words of Robert Browning who
nearly two centuries ago wrote glad was
I when I reached the other bank now now
for a better country the members in this
chamber will reject my candidacy today I
understand that but ours is a vision for
that better country you will not find a
prospectus more positive or more
ambitious from anyone else because
liberal Democrats believe in Scotland
that is industrious Innovative and
internationalist of Outlook I want us to
imagine things again to make things
again to harness the collective
potential of our peoples and our natural
resources as Scotland that delivers for
those working in our schools in our
hospitals and in our Fields they are
tired of the ministerial disinterest
that is characterized much of this past
16 years they are tired of a government
fixated on the breakup of the United
Kingdom
we have to put the people first liberal
Democrats understand what matters to
them because we ask them door by door
and Street by Street in The Villages and
towns of Scotland they want to know when
they will get that hip replacement they
want to know why their kid has been left
behind in school or is a lot left
waiting for mental health treatment they
want to know why they have to live in a
cold home
they're looking to this chamber for
answers that is why I'm in politics it's
what keeps me awake at night resigning
officer liberal Democrats would cut
waiting times then abandon the SNP
paragram of social care we would deliver
an emergency installation program that
makes every home a warm one while
slashing our carbon emissions and we
would strive to make our classrooms
inviting places to work and to learn by
always paying our teachers what they are
worth tackling violence in our schools
and scrapping National testing liberal
Democrats are by Nature Solutions Focus
we are crackling with policy ideas and
my goodness don't we need some of them
right now presiding officer our world is
changing Scotland faces big
International questions our world is on
fire in the climate emergency we are
witness to the mass displacement of
those fleeing unimaginable atrocities
and we will come to look back on this
time with an understanding that we were
already living in the early days of a
new Cold War these challenges demand a
new kind of politics it is a politics of
Hope of democratic reform a politics of
common Endeavor across Nations that
share our values and our corner of this
world so I stand today on that ticket
because the Scottish liberal Democrats
are the party of Cooperative cooperation
across these islands the party of local
power through federalism and yes the
true party of Europe make no mistake
there is make no mistake there is more
water behind this government than lies
ahead of it change is coming and liberal
Democrats will be part of what's next if
we want it to that change could start
with this vote this afternoon we don't
have to set up for continuity for
mediocrity for more of the divisive and
dreary same that other bank could
actually be in sight we just have to
reach for it now for about better
country thank you
thank you I call on Douglas shorts thank
you very much presiding officer in 2021
I put myself forward as my Party's
candidate for first Minister because I
believe Scotland needed a real
alternative an alternative focused on
the big challenges that our country was
facing now at the end of the sturgeon
era and our fractious SMP leadership
election it's clear that alternative is
still needed
this nationalist government is moving
further and further away from the real
priorities of Scottish people like
helping struggling families through the
global cost of living crisis helping
those who want to see our Scottish
economy flourish once more and
rebuilding our demoralized and
overstretched NHS those are the big
challenges that we are facing today and
those are the challenges that Scottish
people want every single one of us msps
in this chamber to be leads are focused
on
yeah instead we've seen from the party
of government
them being consumed by the debate on
Independence and furthering their
nationalist obsession
the SNP have been fiddling for room
Burns they've abdicated responsibility
for governing our country in favor of
again attempting to reboot the entire
campaign for separation
and Andre Youssef has been at the
Forefront of this debate
he said that every election should be
about independence
he has proclaimed himself to be the
first activist of the Nationalist
movement
and yesterday in his very first act as
leader of his party he demanded another
Independence referendum from the UK
government
thank you let's hear Mr Ross
an image if you needed it that the
nationalists had the wrong priorities
for this country
[Applause]
because at a time when our country needs
National leadership we have yet again
been given another nationalist leader
but one even more divisive than the last
Hamza Yusuf will not bring Scotland
together he will not focus on the big
challenges facing our economy our public
services and families up and down the
country
over the last month he has been running
our NHS part-time while prioritizing his
own leadership Ambitions in in this
thank you members
in this his final day as health
secretary figures show that just 63 of
patients were seen at a e within the
target time
down from 87 when he was given that most
important job within government and his
fellow Cabinet member Kate Forbes was
absolutely right to be scathing about
his record in government and it turns
out that almost half of SNP members in
this election agreed with her
Scotland needs a real alternative
focused on the big challenges our
country is facing and that's why as
leader of the main opposition party in
this chamber I'm putting myself forward
for the position of first minister
no we already know the way the votes are
going to go Hamza Yusuf has stitched up
a backroom deal with the greens to keep
his nationalist government thank you
I'll just repeat it Hamza Yusuf has
stitched up a backroom deal with the
greens to keep his nationalist
government in power and with an
anti-growth party within government
sadly Scotland will be the poorer as a
result
but today
also about the future
because the contest that the s p have
just been through shows Beyond any doubt
that the s p are not invincible
that continued nationalist government in
Scotland is not inevitable
as we enter into their post-surgeon era
we can see that the post SMP Scotland is
also in reach a chance to bend the
Nationalist never endings and put the
real priorities of Scottish people first
it's past tight that the S paid the
price for their failures in government
and single-minded focused on dividing
our country with another Independence
referendum
and in communities across Scotland the
Scottish conservatives are the only
party that can beat the SNP in both next
year's general election and the next
Scottish Parliament election to make
that happen
over the last two years my party has
been building a positive program focused
on the real challenges Scotland faces
thank you I'm not sure why SMP members
laugh but I'm about to speak about but
I'm about to speak about the right to
recovery bill
the right to recovery bill that we
publish that will tackle Scotland's drug
test Scandal and has now been endorsed
by all sides of this chamber we set out
our plans for a rural development Bank
to invest in infrastructure that rural
communities and Pharmacy farming
businesses need to thrive we're bringing
forward a victims law that would ensure
that we place the justice system on the
side of victims nor criminals set out
plans for a rent-to-own model and tax
cuts for first-time buyers that would
ensure that home ownership in Scotland
is not an unaffordable dream but can
become reality and we have plans to
deliver a skills Revolution to ensure
that every Scott has a right to retrain
these are just some of the positive
policies from the platform that we have
been building presiding officer today
nationalists in this chamber will give
Hamza Yusuf a blank check to again push
forward his party's Independence
Obsession but in the elections to come
Scotland can make the s p pay the price
for ignoring our real priorities and in
so many areas across Scotland the
Scottish conservatives are the only
party that can make that happen thank
you
thank you I call on Anna sarwar
presenting officer Scotland's incoming
first Minister has been left with an
overflowing entry to deal with
our country is in the group of two
devastating crises an NHS crisis brought
about by the current SMP
administration's failure to prepare and
the cost of living crisis created in
Downing Street the rising bills higher
food costs and rampant inflation
our next first Minister must urgently
prioritize these challenges the people
of Scotland will expect nothing less
and they will not forgive if first
Minister who chooses instead to focus on
their own priorities
I pledge to always put the people's
priorities first
because following Nicholas sturgeon's
long period in office we need a first
Minister for all of Scotland not just if
first Minister for half of the country
[Applause]
same is the is an acceptance of
mediocrity continuity won't cut it
the conclusion of the better SMP
leadership contest does not bring an end
to the division and incompetence that's
been on display in recent weeks and when
we look at that entry awaiting in blue
house it's clear that we need a first
Minister without the distractions of a
broken political party behind them and
without the culture of secrecy and
cover-up which has been the Hallmark of
16 years of SMP government
a regime that has left us with record a
e waiting times with one in seven Scots
on an NHS waiting list record drug
deaths record vacancies for nurses and
doctors in our NHS record levels of
homelessness an entrenched attainment
Gap falling business numbers the fairy
Scandal broken promises on green jobs
devastating cuts to councils
and only last week the damning verdict
on child poverty in the Scottish
government's own report little recent
change
we need change people across our country
are crying out for the answers to the
real issues that they are facing
our task is to show that Scotland can
have a better more exciting and more
prosperous future if we unleash our
country's potential
a better future for Scotland starts with
a plan a plan to unlock the
extraordinary talents and innovation of
the Scottish people a plan where we
create more highly paid jobs high-tech
Industries and more chances to reskill
so the working people in Scotland are
better off
Scotland with our public services are
once again the Envy of the world
Scotland is crying out for change very
new for SNP first Minister isn't going
to be enough
Scotland needs something different than
a continuity candidate
after years of failure under this SNP
Administration we need a first Minister
who truly believes in the extraordinary
potential of the Scottish people because
I know our country can do so much better
but we need a first minister with a
political will the belief in our people
and our nation and the driving ambition
to deliver the change Scotland needs a
first minister with a determination to
save our NHS by increasing capacity in
anes providing better NHS 24 support
freeing up beds and valuing our NHS
staff by improving working conditions
a first Minister willing to listen to
the worries of people and businesses
across Scotland as you struggle with the
cost of living crisis and who's prepared
to take action to help
a first Minister who recognized that
being green isn't about propping up a
failed government and return for
ministerial jobs but it's actually about
delivering actual green jobs and putting
Scotland at the heart of the UK's
renewable Revolution
it's about having a plan that delivers
economic growth and Innovation
encourages good business and supports
employees it's about fulfilling the
promise of home ownership that has been
dashed for far too many in Scotland and
it's about refusing to accept the little
recent change is good enough when it
comes to tackling poverty but instead
makes it the defining mission of the
office of first minister
now I know everyone in this chamber has
made up their mind and it isn't open to
persuasion but I'm more interested in
winning the debate in the country than
in this chamber
because people across this country
deserve better than a government focused
on their own priorities rather than
yours
so my promise to those watching across
Scotland I will work day and night to
earn your trust and to win your support
because this isn't as good as it gets
change is possible and I am determined
that the Scottish labor party I lead
will deliver the change Scotland needs
thank you
[Applause]
as I call on Hamza Yusuf
presenting officer it is a privilege of
my life to stand before you and fellow
msps as a nominee for first minister of
Scotland well I of course have made up
my mind who I'm voting for can I thank
the other nominees for their remarks
when my predecessor made her opening
contribution on this occasion in 2014.
she rightly remarked that two female
Party leaders herself in with Davidson
being nominated was a good advert for
modern Scotland she was of course right
it was also quite a signal of the
progress that we have made as a country
as well as a parliament that two of the
candidates putting themselves forward
are from a minority ethnic communities
that a majority of msps in this
Parliament belong to parties led by two
people of color two people of the Muslim
faith and the fact that no one no one
bats an eyelid at this tells me we are
making progress in our nation for which
we should all be very very Road
ahead of the vote I intend to keep my
comments uh relatively brief there is no
doubt at all that Nicholas surgeon
leaves some very big shoes to fill
indeed as well as her many domestic
achievements which I hope to pay tribute
to after Parliament has voted she has
built up an international profile for
the office of first Minister which
leaders of many independent countries
never mind devolved governments could
only dream of the fact that Scotland is
playing such a significant role on many
of the key international issues of the
day such as tackling climate change
renewable energy the roaming economy is
down in a huge part to her leadership
everyone holding office of first
minister no matter their views in
Scottish independence should aspire to
do likewise and if Parliament votes for
me today I pledge that I will continue
to ensure that Scotland is a positive
Progressive voice on the world stage
over the last few weeks I and my fellow
SMP candidates have had the pleasure of
traveling the length and breadth of
Scotland participating in party
hosting's debates and also meeting with
countless local businesses Community
groups and members of the public there's
no doubt that people and businesses are
feeling the significant pressures of the
cost of living crisis the first job of
any first minister is to keep people
safe and to lead them through the tough
times and if elected that is exactly
what I intend to do by presiding officer
what I've also seen over the last few
weeks is that people are optimistic they
are ambitious about the future of
Scotland we must always give people hope
we've come through so much together as
the country particularly in the last few
years and we've demonstrated a
resilience that many of us thought we
did not have it is often in the darkest
of hours that we see the best of
humanity no no more no more is this true
than during of course the global
pandemic
in tough times it's often easy to forget
how lucky we are to live in a country
blessed with such immense natural
resources and human Talent one which is
brimming with potential and Ingenuity so
I very firmly believe that Scotland's
best days lie in front of us and as
first Minister I will work tirelessly to
make sure that is the case
presiding officer I have been privileged
to hold ministerial office for over a
decade and in that time I think it's
fair to say I've been tested in what
some people I'm sure most people would
agree are some of the toughest roles in
government and I've never shied away
from those responsibilities in fact I
see it as an honor to be entrusted with
them I've always believed that
leadership is about running towards and
embracing challenges rather than shying
away from them we might not be able to
achieve everything we want all of the
time and all at once but every day in
office is an opportunity to make things
a bit better than they were yesterday
and I will always be impatient to go
faster
and if the chamber chooses me today as
their nomination for first Minister I
will never shy away from tackling the
big issues that our country faces I will
lead a government that listens carefully
and respects the views of all msps my
starting point will always be that we
all want the best for Scotland and the
people that we are so privileged to
represent and I will stand up
unequivocally for this Parliament and
against any attempts to undermine
Devolution I will work every hour of
every day to harness the potential of
Scotland and every single person in it I
will place no limits on the Ambitions
that we have collectively for ourselves
for our country or indeed for the world
that we live in
foreign
before we move on to the vote there'll
be a short suspension to allow members
to access the digital voting system
thank you we now move to voting
yeah can we have um yes thank you thank
you colleagues we now move to voting and
may I remind members that they must vote
once only and must only use their yes
button in the voting app when voting
if any member records a vote other than
a yes vote we will rerun the voting
question
once once the voting for candidates is
completed members who have not voted for
a candidate will then be given the
opportunity to vote to abstain by
pressing the yes button and I will
announce the results once all votes have
been cast and verified
the first vote is for Alex Cole Hamilton
only members who wish to cast their vote
for Alex cool Hamilton should take part
in this vote by voting yes
no other members should vote members who
wish to vote for outschool Hamilton
should vote Yes now
hello
we move on to the next vote
and the next Fort is for Douglas Ross
only members who wish to cast their vote
for Douglas Ross should take part in
this vote by voting yes
no other member should vote members who
wish to vote for Douglas Ross should
vote Yes now
thank you
talk to me
the fort is closed
I call Ross McCall for a point of order
sorry I wouldn't connect I would have
voted yes
thank you we'll ensure that's recorded
Mr McCall
we move on to the next Fort and the next
vote is for Anna sarwar only members who
wish to cast their vote for Anna sarwar
should take part in this vote by voting
yes no other members should vote and
members who wish to vote for anasarawa
should vote Yes now
foreign
we move on to the next vote the next
vote is for Hamza Yusuf only members who
wish to cast their vote for Hamza Yusuf
should take part in this vote by voting
yes no other members should vote members
who wish to vote for Hamza Yusuf should
vote Yes now
is
the vote is closed
I can confirm that you have voted Mr
Stewart okay thank you
I can confirm that your vote has been
recorded
come on
I can confirm that your vote has been
recorded Miss Stevenson thank you
point of order Mr Kelvin it's just
Frozen translating officers of double
check out the voltage yes of course
I can confirm that your vote has been
recorded Mr McKelvey thank you
thank you that concludes the votes for
all candidates the next vote is for any
members who have not yet voted and who
wish to record an abstention members
wishing to abstain should press their
yes button now
today
The Vault has closed
that concludes this round of voting and
there will now be a suspension while the
votes are verified
thank you
thank you members
in this round
in this round of voting in the selection
of the parliament's nominee as first
Minister the number of votes cast for
each candidate is as follows
Alex Cole Hamilton for
Douglas Ross 31 Anna sarwar 22.
Hamza Yusuf 71.
as an overall majority has been reached
the candidate selected as the
parliament's nominee for the position of
first minister is Hamza Yusuf
[Applause]
foreign
thank you I I will now call each of the
party leaders to respond and I now call
Douglas Ross
thank you very much for saying the
officer and can I begin by recognizing
this historic moment I want to
congratulations personally on his
election I know what an honor it will be
for him and how proud that will make his
family watching here today and I also
want to congratulate him as the first
person of an ethnic minority to become a
first minister
with both the first Minister and the
Prime Minister representing the UK's
diverse communities it seems a strong
positive message to everyone that there
are no barriers to what you can achieve
in this country and I think that's
something
that's probably where the consensus is
going to end but they are genuine
heartfelt
because
um I have to see regrettably the new
first Minister seems to be doing his
best to imitate his predecessor instead
of setting out a platform to focus on
Scotland's real priorities Hamza Yusuf
has confirmed that he wants to continue
the Constitutional conflict with UK
government continuing to attempt to
appeal to his divided party rather than
the wider Scottish public the record
player has changed but the tune Remains
the Same and I think history will look
back and judge this to be a massive
missed opportunity for our country
for we on this side of the chamber will
always look to cooperate with the
Scottish government when it is
exclusively focused on tackling the big
challenges that Scotland faces the tone
that Hamza Yusuf has set for his
government in choosing to double down on
his party's Independence Obsession
suggests that those moments may be few
and far between
so the Scottish conservatives will hold
tons of use of government to account
when it Strays away from the key
challenges facing Scotland today and we
will always stand up in this Parliament
for the ideas and values that represent
the real priorities of Scottish people
I know that with the election of Yusuf
as leader we remain in the position that
I am the only party leader that doesn't
represent a seat in one of Scotland's
two largest cities and that gives the
Scottish conservatives additional
responsibilities to stand up for all of
our Villages towns and cities to be a
champion for Rural Scotland and to
represent the whole country
and I also know with tons of users
election to head up the SNP I'm now the
only leader of a major political party
in Scotland not to have been privately
educated at Hutchinson's grammar school
instead instead coming from a
working-class background I attended my
local schools at Arvest primary and
Forest Academy
and increasingly
and increasingly it is the Scottish
conservatives that represent the values
of work in Scotland in this chamber as
we have shown time and time again on the
gender Reform Bill on the heat crime act
and our name persons it was the Scottish
conservatives who were the only voice
speaking up for the views of a clear
majority of the Scottish public
a presiding officer voters across
Scotland expect the parties in this
chamber to focus on their priorities not
their own political obsessions and any
party that fails to do so should be the
price for that failure we were all
elected to solve the big challenges
facing Scotland and today those
challenges are as Stark as ever
an NHS in crisis families struggling
with the coastal living crisis an
underperforming Scottish economy it's
incumbent on all of us to focus on these
issues let's get on with the job of
tackling them for the people of Scotland
thank you
thank you and I know Paul anisawar
training officer on behalf of Scottish
labor I offer my sincerest
congratulations to Hamza Yusuf on being
nominated as our next first Minister
alhamdul and I have known each other for
many years and I know that he and his
family will rightly enjoy a feeling of
Pride today and what he has achieved and
a special thought for his wife his
beautiful girls his mom and dad and of
course his sister they are rightly proud
today and regardless of our politics we
should take I'll take immense Pride to
this country is to have its first
minority ethnic first Minister whatever
our political differences and there'll
be many in the months ahead today's
significance cannot be understated it is
something our grandparents would never
ever have imagined when they arrived in
this country and made Scotland their
home but reaching this historic moment
has not been easy and I know that he has
faced personal abuse and racism as of so
many others who don't have the platform
that he and I are fortunate to have so
I'm proud of what that we have done
alongside others to stand against hatred
and bigotry and my promise I will
continue to stand alongside you in that
fight for all of us
oh
and extending my congratulations to
Hamza Yusuf on being appointed as the
first Forest Minister for my minority
ethnic background for all these reasons
I hope he's not the last and in the
meantime however as I said in my remarks
earlier we need a first Minister for all
of Scotland during the SNP leadership
contest which we have all watched with
disbelief I understand he had to Pander
to his party faithful by promising to
prioritize independence by our gym now
to leave the inward looking and divisive
approach behind and work on behalf of
every person in our country regardless
of their constitutional position because
nothing is more important right now than
the twin crises in our that our nation
faces the NHS crisis created by this SNP
government and the cost of living crisis
exacerbated by the Tories and that's not
all that's in the entry the new first
Minister has been left to pick up a
catalog of failure by his predecessors
and the challenge ahead is immense after
15 years of SMP rule not a single
institution in Scotland is stronger and
I hope this moment ushers in some better
governance for the people of Scotland
but if I'm honest I don't hold out that
hope it is clear that the SMP does not
have the answers that Scotland needs the
first Minister now leads a chaotic and
divided party out of touch and out of
ideas there are those who have described
who would describe today's events as a
coronation without an election you could
even say quoting a farce inflicted on
Scotland and that the SNP has failed a
democratic test I know that might cause
discomfort with someone the government
mentors but these aren't my words
they're the words of John Swinney when
he was making their speech in 2001.
because while Mr Youssef has inherited
the snp's war for record he has not
inherited Nicola sturgeon's mandate
that's why we need an election because
only through a change of government will
we be able to truly deliver the better
governance that Scotland needs
so if the first minister is as he
describes himself a democracy Defender
he would call that election now
but if he likes the courage for that
then the least we can ask is that he
used the power of government to change
people's lives for the better this
Parliament has the immense power to
change Scotland that should be the
opportunity ahead of us so again my
promise where we can find consensus or
common cause in this chamber we should
work together when we disagree as we
inevitably will from these benches we
will always attempt to offer positive
alternatives it is the job of everyone
in this chamber to look to the Future
not to the past and to help realize the
unfulfilled potential of devolution we
can do that if we rise to the ambition
of the people of Scotland for that I
will strive every day he must do the
same thank you
[Applause]
Lorna Slater
presiding officer my Scottish green
colleagues and I were delighted to vote
for Hamza Yusuf as our next first
minister
this follows on the unanimous decision
by our party Council yesterday to
continue with the Butte house agreement
between the Scottish greens and the
Scottish government
today represents a historic Milestone
our youngest ever first Minister our
first Muslim leader and the first
minority ethnic leader of a devolved
government in the UK
it also represents the continuation of
our historic agreement which brought
greens into government for the first
time in the UK
Hamza Yusuf has been a great supporter
of the Butte house agreement that
support has been consistent and strong
throughout the last six weeks and for
that he has my and my party's gratitude
presiding officer let me take this
opportunity to remind the chamber why
the house agreement is so important to
us and to the future of Scotland
firstly the agreement is built on a
shared commitment to constructive
collaborative grown-up politics a
politics which Builds on good faith and
trust as core values
the kind of grown-up collaborative
politics that this Parliament was
designed to embody that citizens take
for granted in other modern European
countries
we sit here today in this horseshoe
shape for a reason
the design of this chamber seeks to be a
rejection of the adversarial opposition
for opposition's sake style of
Westminster politics
like so many parliaments across Europe
here in Hollywood we sit together in a
semicircle to build consensus across the
chamber
secondly the house agreement reflects
the pro-independence ambition which
Scotland voted for in 2021
it delivers a government that is
committed to Scotland becoming a modern
independent nation at the heart of the
European Union
I look forward to the two parties of
government continuing to build and make
that case
finally the agreement is based on a bold
and Progressive policy platform that is
making Scotland fairer and greener I am
proud of what we have already delivered
in the first 18 months of our
collaborative government and emergency
rent freeze free bus travel for young
people record funding for the nature and
climate emergencies doubling the
Scottish child payment an active travel
investment program that Rivals the best
of our European Neighbors an energy
strategy that recognizes that we need to
leave oil and gas in the ground and more
I look forward to building on those
successes delivering more for the people
of Scotland our climate and our
environment
because presiding officer our work has
only just begun
from delivering on our commitment to
create highly protected Marine areas so
that our oceans can regenerate after
Decades of decline to a bold new climate
plan
we will deliver a Greener Scotland
from bringing in permanent rent controls
and new rights for tenants to delivering
new Social Security protections we will
deliver a fairer Scotland
and from Banning cruel conversion
practices and bringing in safe access
zones around abortion clinics we will
deliver a more compassionate Scotland
presiding officer let me conclude by
saying that my Scottish green colleagues
and I look forward to working with the
new first Minister and Scottish
government to deliver a fairer Greener
independent Scotland it is needed now
more than ever before
thank you I now call Alex Paul Hamilton
and thank you very much presenting
officer can I begin as others have done
by offering the congratulations of the
Scottish liberal Democrats to himself on
his nomination as first Minister and
wish him and his family who are here in
the gallery today are belated Ramadan
Mubarak that a person of his faith and
ethnicity can Ascend the highest office
in the land is truly a historic moment
in the progress of our nation I hope he
was made to feel welcome in murrayfield
yesterday members may recall that he was
in fact there four weeks ago during the
recent Council by-election I believe
it's a sign of things to come that his
presence and involvement in that
campaign saw the SNP lose a third of
their vote and the seat to the liberal
Democrats in what was the largest
by-election victory in my party's
history
presiding opposite I first got to know
I've always got to know who I'm the ESF
during a different Ramadan 11 years ago
I was in Youth work at the time and I
took him on a community shift in govern
fasting he had not had a drop of water
or anything to eat and we walked for
nine miles over five hours talking to
young people along the way and engaging
them in activities as he'd been recently
elected he didn't want his local
recognition to get in the way of his
interactions with young people we met so
he asked myself and the other youth work
is to introduce him simply as Harry and
we Julie did that everything went fine
he passed on without recognition until
one young while we met in Elder Park
typed up yeah but aren't you Harry
Youssef off the telly
presiding officer the measure of
effective leadership is to listen to and
to recognize that a good idea is a good
idea and regardless of whether it comes
from those kids in govern or from the
opposition benches is being willing to
reach across the aisle when times get
tough like we all did in the early days
of the pandemic and the measure of
effective leadership is to raise the
standard of public debate above the
divisions of the past it's about growing
up politics in 16 years we haven't seen
a great deal of that the new first
Minister has said he will talk to all
opposition leaders I welcome that and he
has my number and I will tell him about
our desire to see a dedicated mental
health Minister who will actually clear
down waiting lists I will tell him about
the desperate need for more support and
meaningful care Pathways for nearly two
hundred thousand Scots suffering long
covert about the mums in the far north
forced to travel two hours down the
treacherous A9 to give birth because
their maternity unit was closed about
how we could lift detainment in our
schools through a nursery premium and by
attracting and retaining the best
teachers about the pig's ear of a good
idea that is a deposit return scheme
which will take Scottish produce off
Scottish shelves and about why this
government needs to stop The Dumping of
raw sewage in our rivers and on our
beaches I could go on because there is a
disconnect between the focus of the
governing parties and the needs and
interests of this country people are
turning away from the divisions of the
past and their patience for those who
deviate from what matters to them is
finite change is coming
for both of our governments we need to
fix our broken politics and restore
Integrity I didn't Prevail today but
just like in murrayfield change is
coming and the Scottish liberal
Democrats will be part of what's next
but for now I want to recognize this is
a significant day for himself as it is
for the diversity in our country well
done Harry
thank you and I now call on Hamza Yusuf
can I um thank the other party leaders
for the remarks I'm aware very aware of
course that they may never be so nice to
me again and while the vote to me have
seemed like a formality the fact that a
few of my colleagues raised the point of
order just after voting for me did raise
my blood pressure ever so slightly and
let me also remind Anna Sawa in
particular that I have his father's
number on speed dial so if he's not nice
to me I will be having words
um the generosity of comments that have
been made matches the spirit of the
remarks that were made by Donald dure 24
years ago when he became Scotland's
first first Minister Donald dure
emphasized and I quote the common aims
that we share across this chamber of
giving people a better life and a better
future the government I lead will
dedicate itself very much to those apps
and I hope to work with colleagues
across the chamber in doing so and this
is a proud day for me a proud day for my
family and I can hear my three-year-old
speaking and waving to me from the
chamber and only on my second page
darling there's a few little bit more to
come it is a really proud day for me and
my family I hope it's also a proud day
for Scotland as it speaks to our values
as a country as I stand here as the
first ever Muslim to lead a western
Democratic Nation you try telling that
to 16 year old Thomas the Yusuf who post
911 was questioned constantly about his
loyalty to this country we have
presenting officer collectively come a
long way I am joined by too many family
members and friends to mention but I
hope the chamber will indulge me
presiding officer as there's a few that
I would like to mention my mom and dad
have always been unwavering in their
support of me as a young Scottish Asian
it was often the norm of expectation
that we would end up as either doctors
dentists pharmacists accountants or
lawyers but I remember vividly the
nerves I felt and the Very pit of my
stomach the day I decided to tell my
parents that I wanted to study politics
instead of law
far from giving me as my mum put it in
news reports yesterday a clip around the
ear they could not have been more
supportive saying it was vital it was
important that people like us were also
represented in politics from that day to
this very moment they have encouraged me
every single step of the way I could not
be making history without them
to my wife or my girls you are my
everything I'm being first Minister will
not change that it may mean that you see
me slightly less often but to my
three-year-old Amal in particular be
aware there are plenty of stairs in your
house so if you misbehave there will
still be a naughty statements
though so far I am pleased that everyone
seems to be on their best behavior
presiding officer
the years after 9 11 were not easy for
Muslims growing up in Scotland or indeed
across the UK I've lost count of how
many times my identity my loyalty to
Scotland the only country I have ever
and will ever call home has been
questioned over the years
there was a time not all that long ago
when I fell I simply did not belong here
in Scotland
to grow to go from there to now leading
the government as Scotland's sixth first
Minister I hope sends a strong message
to every single person out there who
feels that they don't belong
no matter what anyone says no matter who
you are whether Scotland has been your
home for a day or for 10 Generations no
matter your ethnicity no matter your
gender
no matter your religion no matter your
sexual orientation your transgender
Identity or disability this is your home
and do not let anyone ever tell you that
you are not good enough do not let
anyone ever tell you that you do not
belong and as first Minister I will
always fight for your rights and where
possible I will do everything I can to
advance them
I will always stand up for social
justice more widely and for making
Scotland a fairer as well as a wealthier
nation a key priority of my government
will be to protect every Scot as far as
we can from the harm that has been
inflicted by the cost of living crisis
one of my first conversations as first
Minister will be with anti-poverty
groups to explore what more we can do
within our devolved powers to tackle
child property
we will protect and we will reform our
NHS and social care and other vital
public services to support our
well-being economy to improve the life
chances of people right across our
country we will rapidly develop plans to
extend Child Care improve rural housing
support small businesses and boost
Innovation we will keep the promise that
we have made to people with experience
of the care system not just young people
it's important as of course as that is
but we recognize that care experience is
lifelong we will bring forward reforms
of the Criminal Justice System continue
our work to reduce drugs death and
create a new deal with local government
to empower our local authorities to meet
the challenges of the day we will
support businesses we will seize the
economic and social opportunities of a
just transition to Net Zero and we will
continue to ensure that Scotland uses
its voice on the international stage
on Thursday I will nominate the team of
ministers who will deliver on those
priorities I will then set out more
detailed policies to this chamber in the
first week after the Easter recess I
will be very proud to build on the
record of the government that has been
led by Nicola sturgeon and John Swinney
the Scottish child payment the expansion
of child care Scotland's International
Leadership and the transition to Net
Zero their championing of equality
through all of those achievements in
many more besides Nicholas sturgeon and
John Swinney have both left a
significant Legacy of which I am very
very grateful to them for but I know
there's also so much more to come from
both of them well certainly once Nicole
has finished taking her driving Theory
test of course I will also continue as
they did to argue tirelessly for
Independence in my view and it is of
course the view of the majority in this
Parliament that we will be able to
deliver on our priorities more more
effectively when Scotland is independent
and we will certainly deliver them less
effectively if we allow the UK
government to arbitrarily veto this
parliament's legislation
unsurprisingly I will also argue
vigorously for our independence and
while I do that of course I understand
that the strongest argument this
government can make for Independence is
to make the best possible use of this
parliament's existing Powers I want to
reach out to other parties across the
chamber as I do that that's why the
point I want to end on today is not so
much about what this government will do
but how we will do it at the start of my
speech I stress the common aims the
common values that we all share
listening to many of the remarks made in
the chamber not just today but also
after Nicole sturgeon's statement last
Thursday I think that there is probably
a shared appetite across this chamber
for a politics that is slightly less
polarized and a bit less confrontational
this government already Works in
cooperation with the green party under
the bureau house agreement that will
continue but I also want to make an open
offer to all leaders of all parties in
this chamber this isn't an offer that is
made naively I know that we will
continue quite frequently to disagree
forcefully that is as it should be
politics acquires strong reason
respectful disagreement but for all
those disagreements I also know that we
share many areas of Common Ground
including many of the areas that have
been outlined not just by me but by each
party leader today that's why I will
request early meetings with the leaders
of other parties in this chamber I want
to work with you where we can to achieve
those shared aims I believe there is a
willingness for that in this chamber and
there's a desire for it right across
this country
and just as I will reach out within this
Parliament I will reach out Beyond this
Parliament too to the UK government I
want to stress that I will work with you
where I can when I can in the best
interests of our nation
to our Vital Partners in local
government the business Community the
third sector and The Wider public sector
I promise that this government will
listen to you and will work with you
and above all else to the people of
Scotland I want to make this pledge I
will never forget that I am first
Minister for all of Scotland regardless
of who you voted for where you live or
where you've come from
yesterday I mentioned my grandparents
I've also thought a lot in recent days
of my great friend and Mentor the late
Bashir Ahmed
he also came to Scotland in the 1960s he
started off driving buses he became the
first member of this Parliament from an
ethnic minority he was by far the
kindest and most gentle soul I have ever
known and if we were all a little bit
more like bashia than I think our world
would be in a far better place
he used to say that it isn't important
where you come from what matters is
where we are going together as a nation
it is a phrase I think of often it's a
phrase which will guide how I and my
government governs this Parliament has
just given me the opportunity to help
steer this nation's course
as we make the next stage of that
journey together doing that will be the
honor and the privilege of my life I
will strive every single minute of every
day to be worthy of it I look forward to
working with each and every one of you
as I do and the best interest of our
nation thank you
right
thank you
on behalf of the parliament I would like
to congratulate tanza Yusuf as the
parliament's nominee for the position of
first Minister I look forward to working
with you that concludes the selection of
first Minister and it is now time to
move on to the next item of business
which is consideration of business
motion
eight four three four in the name of
George Adam on behalf of the
Parliamentary Bureau setting out a
business program and I call on George
Adam to move the motion thank you
president officer and moved thank you
minister no member has asked to speak on
the motion therefore the question is
that motion 8434 be agreed are we all
agreed
the motion is therefore agreed
the next item of business is
consideration of five parliamentary
Bureau motions and asked George Adam on
behalf of the Parliamentary Bureau to
move motions
8435-8438 on approval of ssis and 8439
on designation of a lead committee
every single one of them moved thank you
the question on these motions will be
put at decision time and I'm minded to
accept emotion without notice under rule
11.2.4 of standing orders the decision
time B brought forward to now and I
invite the minister to move the motion
be happy to move presiding officer thank
you the question is that decision time
be brought forward to now are we all
agreed we are agreed and there is one
question to be put as a result of
today's business
I propose to ask a single question on
five parliamentary Bureau motions does
any member object
no member objects therefore the question
is that motions
8435-8438 on approval of ssis and 8439
on designation of lead Committee in the
name of George Adam on behalf of the
Parliamentary Bureau be agreed are we
all agreed the Motions are therefore
agreed and that concludes decision time
and we will now move on to members
business
there will be a brief suspension to
allow the gallery and the Chamber to
clear
[Applause]
thank you
um
[Music]